مساعدات لاوكرانيا مساله كانت محط خلاف
بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين عند التصويت
على مشروع قانون الماليه الامريكي في
اللحظه الاخيره تجنبت الولايات المتحده
الاغلاق الحكومي من خلال تمديد التمويل
مؤقتا لكن هذه الميزانيه لا تتضمن مساعدات
لاوكرانيا امر حذر منه جو
بايدن اريد ان اؤكد
لحلفائه يمكن الاعتماد على دعمنا لن ننسحب
توقفوا عن الالاعيب افعلوا
اللازم في البدايه طالب البيت الابيض ان
يشمل قانون الماليه الذي صوت عليه
الكونغرس 24 مليار دولار كمساعدات عسكريه
وانسانيه لكيف لكن بعد فشل الاتفاق على
هذه النقطه سيتعين على النواب النظر في
مشروع قانون منفصل حول المساله امر رحب به
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوربي خلال زيارته
لكيف لكي اكون صادقا فوجئنا بان اتفاق
اللحظه الاخيره اتخذ قرارا ناسف له
بشده لم يتطرق الرئيس الاوكراني مباشره
الى موضوع التصويت في الكونجرس فولوديمير
زيلنسكي اكتفى بالتذكير ان لا شيء من شانه
ان يضعف تصميمه على الانتصار في الحرب